therefore this workshop uh possible i
want to
um thank mike jordan here for twisting
my arm into
running this workshop in the first place
and aleister sinclair for
desperately trying to keep me on track
along the way on which more in a moment
um
our organizing committee um who
basically
helped identify the speakers and
structure the program and the themes
that we're hoping will come out
um is deepak agarwal edo araldi uh
ashish goal matt jackson and jen neville
who i want to give special thanks to
because as alistair is aware when i was
lolly gagging around and
the deadline or the date for the
workshop was rapidly approaching
jen stepped in and helped me really make
sense of the program and structure
talks into sessions and try to bring out
themes and kind of you know rally people
to
volunteer to give these brief overviews
at the beginning and lead discussions
and so i'm particularly
grateful to jen for her help um i want
to also thank
carolyn allen of the institute who's
been terrific with logistics and who i
just met this morning but has been
helping remotely um quite a bit all
along
um to say a little bit about the the you
know what i'm hoping to get out of this
workshop so
like many of you i've attended many you
know interdisciplinary
workshops on networks and network
science over the past few years
um that deliberately bring together
people from many different disciplines
who have an interest in
networks of one type or another and
even though these you know workshops
like this one have been deliberately
interdisciplinary
i always felt like there was a bit of a
still of a theory experiment gap and i
think i was colored here by my
by my machine learning experience being
somebody who's primarily a theoretician
still when i go to machine learning
conferences these days it feels like
there's
not just sort of interaction but serious
traffic between people who do
theoretical work and experiment and
there's sort of a loop
if you like where you know theoretical
ideas get tested on experiment which in
turn
suggests an improvement of the
theoretical idea
and this still felt missing to me a
little bit in the you know area that's
become known as network science
so the idea here was not just to be
interdisciplinary but more specifically
to bring together
people who primarily take a theoretical
or formal mathematical view
of networks from many communities
including math computer science
statistics and the like
with people who work with large-scale
network data
and you know think about problems of
estimating networks or estimating
properties of networks or estimating
properties about dynamics on networks
so that was the idea that was the
original impetus for the workshop
and and one of the reasons i'm kind of
excited about this workshop is that
unlike many conferences i go to
i've never met some large fraction of
the speakers
even though i know something about their
work from afar in the past so there's
you know i'm going to meet a lot of new
people myself this week
the the original design for the workshop
was to be this intimate thing where
you know only a few of us would have a
conversation amongst ourselves to really
get traction
um but the forces of the institute are
such that things cannot be done on a
small scale although
if we keep with this this rate of
attrition will think of more or less
fulfilled my original goals which would
be would be fine with me
but you know one of the things i've
asked we've asked speakers to do
is to you know really emphasize
missing research rather than completed
research so you know
everybody's going to talk a little bit
about what they do but what i'm what i'm
really hoping we get out of the talks
are areas where you know we don't know
what the answers are we may not even
know what the questions are we don't
know what the models are
and to get this very diverse set of
people who you know
span the you know span the gap from
theory to um
experiment um to really start talking
with each other in in a meaningful way
so for that reason we've left a lot of
discussion time
i'm hoping we can keep the interactions
very very informal
so we will ask speakers with each in
each session to
um you know come sit on chairs at the at
the end just so that you know we have
have something to look at on the stage
um but but it's it's you know i think
it's completely fine with me and the
rest of the organizing committee
if these discussion sessions are really
discussions amongst the entire audience
and not just sort of extended formal q a
periods for the speakers so please keep
that in mind
um you know by which i mean you should
feel free during the discussions to make
comments that have nothing to do with
any of the talks that you saw
um it doesn't have to be a question for
the the panelists per se
okay um great um so the the basic
organization of each session
is that we've identified somebody from
the organizing committee to be to give
just sort of a brief overview and sort
of talk about what the
um what the theme of the particular
session is
with the understanding that these themes
are imperfect right i mean we sort of uh
you know you you always have to play the
cards that you're dealt and we and jen
did a great job of grouping the talks
into i think coherent sessions
um and so i'm going to do that for the
first session which is on graph models
or or when i kind of look through the
the slides that people sent me in
advance i think really it's about
representation more specifically about
representation of large networks and how
that interacts with data from large
networks
so i'll introduce the speakers in a
group at the beginning then we'll have
them come on and then we'll have one of
these
um free-ranging discussion periods at
the end where we'll turn off the cameras
and we can all get rowdy
um so the four speakers in the first
session are patrick wolf from
university college london uh sebastiano
vigna from the university of milan
uh peter orbans from columbia and matt
salganik from princeton
who's hopefully here there he is hey
matt um
and you know my own subjective take on
the four
talks is that it nicely illustrates this
theory
experiment balance because on the more
theoretical
side amongst the four patrick is going
to start off by talking about network
representations
as large scale limiting behaviors of a
continuous function
and peter will later talk about
exchangeability and sparse graph
applications
or representations and sandwiched in
between those two talks or interspersed
with them sebastiano will talk about
empirical estimation of global
properties in very large networks
including
very interesting work that got some
media attention last year
on facebook data and matt will talk
about
the problem of estimating hiv risk in in
social networks
so with that let me um begin the
proceedings and let patrick get started